OK
然後呢
我們在做完這個Skill之後
其實還是會出現一個問題
叫做他可能當下的時候
是沒有那麼好用的
因為一般來說
一次機出來的東西
他可能會遇到一些極端的情況
他可能會基於你當下
給他的這個任務
只是單純的去解決
你當下這個任務的情況
沒有辦法說
我會到更上一層
從更高的維度去思考你這個問題
那他可能就會出現一些問題
類似於說
誒 觸發不靈密
包括運作的路線跟你不一樣
經常創線你要A
它就給你B
那為甚麼呢
是因為有的時候
因為你當時在做這個Skill的時候
或者是不斷連帶的過程中
他的路線太多
規則混在一起
那大模型沒有辦法的準確的去識別你的意圖
所以回到這件事情上來說
我們就需要去回歸一個東西叫頂層設計
頂層設計上面其實有幾個點
我就簡單跟大家說
因為這一點可能還是比較深的一些東西
所以就不跟大家說太多
我們可以把Skill
理解成一個甚麼
它是一個技能包
對不對
它技能包裡面既包括了技能
也包括了流程
那很多時候我們做一件事情可能比不太安排的愛一個非常固定的流程在做
我們有的時候可能是從中間進去的
我們甚至不需要他做前面的東西
那如果你做了特別這種固化的流程的時候
它可能就會限制死你的流程
也就是說你每次都要從第一步開始
沒有從第一步開始
它就不會不讓你操作
有的時候是會這樣的
所以基於這些點
我們自己在做的過程中
就會做原則化的這樣的一個設定
就是把所有的這些小的步驟
拆成一個又一個的小功能
不單單讓它變成一個大流程
而是讓它變成一個小功能
這樣去做
那第二個點是甚麼
我們叫人工介入
就是很多的時候
比如單單是我做完了一個東西
我就希望它從頭到尾一條龍去解決這個問題
類似於說從輸入了一個brief
它就完整的去出一份方案
這樣其實是不現實的
因為有一些任務
它是需要多個步驟去介入的
它需要你在中間撥亂反正
去在中間去糾正它
所以有的時候一個Skill設計出來
我們在中間的部分
也會去加入人工審核的東西
那第三是工具規類
也就是在一個Skill裡面
它不單單是一些Skill.mp這樣的文字
它也可以做腳本
它也可以做一些工具內線到裡面
類似說公眾號的排帶
排帶器這個東西
它是可以加入到Skill裡面去的
當你把文章寫完了之後
它可以自動的去幫你做排帶
類似於說你做完了一篇
這個稿件
那它可以去幫你直接拆切圖
去切成一張又一張的圖片
那這個都是
它可以去在裡面加入的
你想要的工具化的這件事情
那我用一個最簡單的例子
給大家講清楚
類似於說我這裡做這麼一題
我每天都要處理非常多的
類似於說我要出視頻
我要出這種圖文的
我要出這種公眾號的內容
那我應該怎麼去做呢
我就給自己做了一個大的Skill的包
我在裡面就可以把我所有的
這些過程中的東西全部觸去玩
最簡單的例子
類似於說我打開我的
VS Code
我為甚麼不在
我為甚麼不在我的
那個叫甚麼
就是我們所說的
Condex of the Roadmap裡面去用這個東西
請問大家一下
為甚麼要在這個CloneCode裡面去用
昨天有跟他說寫文字這件事情
我自己是有自己要求的
然後我的Codex裡面沒有接第三方
所以我大多數的時候
我的這個裡面
我是買了
類似於說
昨天給他推薦的這個字圖的會員的
所以我會直接用這個來做
你看這邊其實是我前兩天寫的一篇內容
我的腳本的內容
其實都是AI幫我改掉
全部寫出來的
類似於今天
我不寫這篇了
我直接給他演示一下
假設今天
我會讓他幫我寫一篇文章
請你幫我寫一篇
就是要排視頻的腳本
然後主要來講的內容是
新人如何學習AI的這件事情
請你根據我之前寫過的內容
幫我組織一次
成一篇相應的腳本出來
然後他會去看我這個文件夾裡面的
所有的內容
然後去基於我的口吻
基於我之前的一些知識點
基於我之前的一些判斷
然後從而去
有看到他已經開始在調用這個SKU了
對吧
這個其實就是我自己做的一個SKU
裡面放了我之前的一些沈澱
包括我過去的文章
包括我過去的觀點
然後去調用我在裡面設定的
我的不同的事情
要按甚麼樣的步驟來做的一些SKU
你看他讀了
他自己就開始讀了
兩個多分的文件
然後開始去做這件事情
那這是一個
然後同時呢
舉個例子
那些說我在新建一個
等一下我們再來看他新建的這個文章
幫我打
幫我虛構一篇內容
同時打開我的公眾號的排版器
內置進去排好了
然後他等一下我們可以看到他的整個過程
所以你想要做甚麼事情
你其實去做好自己的一個SKU
他就能夠幫你處理掉非常多的工作
那剛才也跟他說了
為甚麼要用Clonecode
就是因為我的Clonecode裡面接了GLM 5.2
我買了非常多的會員
我天天每次的時候
又會測試這些事情
然後你看他就會開始去讀
開始去寫
然後同時會去找到我之前
去寫過的所有的內容
我就說了一句話而已
對
然後等一下就會看到
他會在這個地方去給我新建項目
然後新建項目
把我們所有的內容去記錄下來
所以是非常快的
就是當你學會GLM AI的這個過程
你生產所有的東西
你會發現哇
怎麼這麼快
就是你所有需要做的事情
就是你要決定
今天要出多少東西
以及怎麼把這個事情做完
他出的東西符合你的要求
你看我剛才說
打開我的排行
排行器去內置進去排行
排行榜這個事情
可能我剛才說的時候有點口誤
其實是內置進去排行榜
但沒有關係
他知道的
就AI有的時候比人還知道
你到底想做甚麼事情的
他只是可能會誤解
你要做一些排行榜的文章
好
他這裡還在讀
因為我裡面的內容很多
等一下
我們再來看這個部分的東西了
那除了說
這種好用的
寫文
工具的技巧
那同時還有一個很重要的東西
就是
我們也可以基於日常的工作
去給自己建一個工作台
那好比說你在公司裡面有中國品牌
營銷
或者是你給自己做個自媒體
那你其實可以
我給大家看一下我的工作台
打開我的工作台
就是我
因為我日常的工作裡面
我有非常多的一些這種魚的事情
我不想去思考
你每天還要來上課
還要來去給企業做培訓服務
然後同時我自己還要做這些證明
包括一些內容
那在這個裡面
復盤
數據的收集
包括一些熱點的追蹤
我還要靠人呢
就每天的時間都給擠掉了
那我自己就會給自己建這種工作台
它就像一個
以前裡面花很多錢
去找給人搭的一個網站
好
我的工作台已經被它打開了
它都沒有
稍等
桌面已經彈出來了
它這個也沒有彈出來
OK
它彈出了這個地方
給大家看一下
我的工作台裡面有甚麼東西
首先
它其實基於我的需求
來給我做的事情
那首先它會有近期的熱點
類似說
會抓到各個平台的實施熱榜
例如說有微博的熱榜
有百度的熱榜
社會的熱榜
那假設我每一天我一起床
我打開我的工作台
我就知道
每個平台目前最熱門的事情是甚麼
有哪些值得我寫的一些選題
那同時在這個裡面呢
也有一些AI的情報
因為我是一個甚麼
我是一個AI國主
所以我要看AI的行業
從昨天到今天
有甚麼熱門的事情
你會發現它已經更新到了
8月30號的周日
8點54分的時候
那這個裡面其實是
介入了一些行業內內
比較流行的
或者說比較權威的一些API
所以你每一天
你都可以打開它的原文去看
它到底在甚麼地方有這個內容
有一些是X上面的
有一些可能是論文的
對吧
不同的
它就會有不同的這些子連接給到你
那同時
因為我還做營銷
因為我有固定的服務的品牌客戶
所以這個是剛才的那個
自己彈出來了
你發現沒有
我剛才想給大家講工作台
然後剛才讓大家看到的那個拍板的
就是打開工作號
虛構一篇文章
然後就虛構一篇文章
然後排好版
中間的這個部分是你可以直接複製到
工作號的後台
它就以這種排好版的形式去搞好它
所以其實都是給大家看一下
這個地方
類似於說
它已經說幫你打開好了
虛構完了
然後放進去了
然後就幫你直接打開了一個網頁
放在這個地方
那你就能看到
哦
這篇內容的標題
證文
包括這個
當然
一般我可以這樣做
因為我寫文章我會先寫完
我會自己先不停的修改
不停修改
我不喜歡這種AI指出的東西
我會自己修改一兩輪三四輪這樣子
然後修改完了之後
我再把我修改完的文章丟給他
讓他去幫我排好版
做功能耗電台的事情是甚麼
是排版
是大家會覺得很煩的時候
那這件事情
其實可以自動去包裝成這樣的一個
直播的內容
然後你在旁邊還可以
你覺得有點些字不在對
你在這邊可以改
改完之後它是同步去反饋到這邊了
然後你最後覺得改完了排好版的東西
你就複製下來就OK
就這麼簡單
然後剛才那篇
這篇我看一下寫完了沒有
好
這一天你看看
已經也幫你寫完了
就在這個地方
然後放在了這個地方
這個BDOS
不是
是我自己做的
你自己的讀書也可以做的
只是它名字叫這個而已
對
它是這個名字而已
它並不是說
也是用overbody
對
你可以用body
或者kodex都可以打出來
打出來
就是它
你可以把它理解了
就是我們剛才說的這個sku
它在本地嗎
它在本地
用不了
對
然後每個人做的東西
其實做的都是給自己用的
我們做一個sku是為了去解決這個工作
當然它可以變成一個產品
但是我目前還沒有把它產品化了
因為我覺得大多數人跟我工作販售不一樣
所以這東西賣給你們也沒有用
所以它更多的就是每個人進入自己的工作
去做一個sku
這個sku裡面需要甚麼功能
你自己的往裡面去填
就OK了
然後我們繼續回到
剛才講的這個工作台的這個部分
那包括說我們做自媒體也好
或者做這種品牌營銷也好
我們需要去看淨品
或者看一些參考的對標
我們也可以抓到
類似小文書上
你自己在關注的一些潛在的博主
他們到底哪些內容是比較爆裂的
然後你可以看到
它寫的甚麼選題
數據非常的好
那同時你也可以抓到
因為我們有一些API
它是可以抓到AI行業
類似說低粉高佔的一些內容
那同時你自己看到有哪些老師的內容
比較好
你也可以把這個鏈接丟給Codex
然後Codex就會幫你把這個老師的
所有的文字稿
全部稿下來
稿完了之後
順便在旁邊幫你分析
它為甚麼好在甚麼地方
所以它等於說在這點的這個部分
對於我來說
它是幫我補足我信心的一個維度
但它已經可以自動
以前像我的話
我需要打開各種不同的網站去瀏覽
其實會非常的亂
而且會有非常多我不想要看到的信息
進入我的腦子裡面
但當你建了一個工作台
你做好了信息篩選
那你每天只需要看到你一些
你想要看到你覺得有高價值的內容
就OK了
這是在任務熱點這個段塊
還有一些任務推進的
任務推進其實我沒甚麼用
因為我所有的任務推進
我是一個比較有自清理的人
所以我不需要有這樣的任務推進來推進我
因為這個東西就有點像你下發任務
給哪個小夥伴或者是這個職員
這一步就沒怎麼做
我都在我的VS Code裡面去做
然後還有一個就是數據的規矩
類似說我會發各種平台
對不對
有的時候你在公司裡面
其實需要把各個平台的數據
拉給你的領導看
或者拉給其他人
你做復盤
不管是做營銷也好
你做別的
你做銷售的
你的銷售數據也要拉給別人看
你各個渠道的銷售數據是不是要收集
那其實也可以通過這樣的一個表格
你會看到每一個月非常明顯的一個變化
它到底每個平台發了多少天
具體數據是怎麼樣的
它的內容
因為我做營銷委
所以我所有的東西都是
for我這種工作
你可以基於這個羅計去改造你日常的工作
如果你是一個銷售
你可能這裡就是不同的渠道數據
甚麼地方賣到甚麼地方
對吧
甚麼地方賣的多甚麼地方賣的少
你每個月都能看得非常清楚
同時因為我自己會去看
我自己到底哪一篇內容的數據好
所以我會收集進來
那同時做完了數據之後
還要做一些事情叫甚麼
叫復盤
你不能只看到數據
你要知道數據好的地方在
為甚麼是好
甚麼地方差
為甚麼是差
那你就需要去做一個月度復盤的東西
那我的月度復盤也是AI初動給我做的
我每個月只需要到月底的時候
然後跑一輪子
然後點開就可以了
類似說它六月份就會告訴我
將上月發佈量是升的
總閱讀量是下降的
然後閱讀的中位數是怎麼樣的
然後同時會告訴我
每一篇文章
它處於我這個象限的甚麼地方
類似說有一些文章
它是高互動
高點
高點在高
高互動的
那它是怎麼樣的
因為互動跟點在它是兩個互動的指標
所以在我們行業裡面
把它分開去看
但我們要找到的就是那種雙光指標的
那種才是經典的好文章
或者是好內容
那我們就會去把不同的這些地方
去點開看
你就能看到每一篇文章
它的數字是怎麼樣的
哪一篇文章它是最好的
對
那我們也能看到每個月不同的數據是怎麼樣的
那下面
每個月下面都會有自動化復盤的這個內容
那同時我又會把我一些高點賬的標題或者甚麼都做到下面
我每天賺的時候就來看一下
所以這個工作台它相當於甚麼東西呢
它相當於我自己對我工作的一個梳理
然後把我工作中不想做的
潤雜的東西
全部通過一個工作台的形式
去自動化的
無論是我想要去組織文章
還是我要去寫好文章後做排斷
還是發佈之後
我的內容的這個數據收集
再到數據收集後的復盤
整個的鏈路已經靠這個小小的SKU
就已經能做完它了
以前的時候你可能要找
你想一想
你在別的間
我相信大多數人的公司
以前講道理都會寄過Agency
就是請過代理商去幫你做廣告
做營銷
做各種代理營
你想想請聽人來做這個事情
他要花多少的錢
他做的質量是怎麼樣的
而現在如果你公司有一個
會做這樣的事情的人
他也懂內容的話
他完全可以自己去構建這樣的
他的系統
把這件事情全保管他
當然這個人是比較值錢的
但是你花在他一個人身上的工資
絕對沒有像說你請聽人
幫你解決這個問題那麼多
所以這才是我們所說的
在一個企業裡面真正落到
降肯增效的地方
在甚麼地方
用了一個非常厲害的人
用了AI
做了一套好的工具
去幫你實現了你以前
可能沒辦法想到的
這樣自動化的一些形式
增加了你們企業的效率
同時達到了降低成的作用
所以這才是我們所說的
真正的一個降肯增效的體力感
OK
講到這裡
我們就剛才跟大家說了
我給大家看了我們的過程
以及一些工作台
然後
其實我們還想跟大家
手措一個簡單的社媒的
時間的問題就算了
其實那個東西
已經在你們的文件夾裡面
有了
我給到大家
大家可以自己有空的時候
去玩一玩
其實很簡單
就是幾個步驟而已
第一步
這個過程
其實如果有空的話
下午我們再跟大家玩玩
因為上午的時間給到我的真的不多
然後像我們這個Channel
跟那裡還有
還有蠻多的那種要給大家講
那這個部分
我就不跟大家講太多
OK
然後我覺得是這樣的
就是因為時間不多
然後我們現在11點半
我們繼續往下講
講完它
講完我這個部分
最後
我們剛才講完了這些skill的部分
然後包括我之前給大家講的
其實都是比較
說打工人怎麼去
在入場的工作裡面去應用
企業的老闆去認知到如何在
到底真正的AI的用法是怎麼樣的
就是很多老闆
會產生一個事情
叫做
不知道就是
AI它到底能用到甚麼地步
以及它編輯在哪裡
都會對它產生
非常非常不著編輯的
或者是那種想象
會覺得它無所不能的幫你
解決這種事情
但是你通過我的演示之後
包括這兩天的接觸以後
你會發現
它可以幫你解決非常多的問題
但前提是甚麼
你也要是一個足夠厲害的人
你要學會去理解中間的門門道道
你要學會專業
那除了這一個部分以外
我們最後再給大家講一點點
企業的自動化落地
也就是現在比較流行的一些趨勢
以及MDE的這些關鍵名詞
它到底是講的是甚麼